okay good morning everybody
welcome to functional web programming in
net with the safe SEC I'm Anthony Brown
if you look into hair call anonymously
there's my twitter or email if you'd
like to do that offline but let's dive
right into it let's jump straight into
functional programming in dotnet so some
of you might be aware that on net there
exist other languages than just C shot
Visual Basic one of which is F shot so
there's a quick introduction to a shop
it's a proper functional programming
language it's based on the ml family of
languages so its history is languages
like oh camel so it's got quite a
different syntax to c-sharp
it runs on net and donate core and it's
not brand new in fact it's been in
development since the early 2000s when
you say functional programming though
one of the things that people here with
that is maths and finance and you always
get the question of why would I want to
use functional programming language all
I'm doing is writing web applications
mobile applications desktop console
whatever and they'll always say isn't a
sharp or FP just for things like maths
or finance etc and the answer to that is
no F sharp is white c-sharp a
general-purpose language it looks
different you write things in a
different way but ultimately everything
runs on the same targets so we use F
sharp to write things like console
applications mobile applications desktop
apps using it and in fact in recent
years we've started to use it to develop
all of our web apps yeah things like
functional programming techniques make
it easy to do really complex tasks like
scalability whether that's like
scalability in terms of users or
scalability in terms of development and
so all these people who are skeptical of
sharp or functional program and we say
to us you know how do you actually do
full stack web development with a shop
and so we put or we put our heads
together and thought about what it is
that we do generally use when we're
writing web applications in a shop and
we came up with this thing called the
safe stack which so we thought the
question was who is we and we is
essentially the come to that I work for
composition IT and a few other people
within the F shop community as well so
the safe stack is the set of tools
libraries frameworks that we use that
make web development in a shop simple
and very easy to get to grips with taken
from the safe website safe is an
end-to-end functional first stack for
cloud ready web development that
emphasizes type safe programming which
is a lot of words to say it's a set of
tools and libraries that allow you to
write web applications from front-end
browser-based applications right the way
through to back-end solutions that run
in the cloud within safe we've got a few
core elements the first thing is a
server-side web application framework
this is you know how you host things
like your API is that you're going to be
calling your HTML templating all of that
kind of thing
you also need somewhere to host it and
run the thing and so for that we've also
included a hosting environment and
platform services there's also a
client-side web application framework so
rather than having to write your
front-end in JavaScript you're able to
write your front-end entirely in a shop
and we've also added a UI framework into
that as well because we ultimately want
to use idiomatic a shop in all of the
front-end API or in front-end
applications that we create so the safe
stack
is represented by these four things
we've got Saturn and giraffe which is
our back-end web web application server
we've got Azure or AWS we primarily use
Azure
but a lot of other people within the
f-sharp community actually use AWS as
their deployment targets F is fable
which is an f-sharp to JavaScript
compiler which lets you run your f sharp
code anywhere that JavaScript would run
and E is elvish which is a UI framework
which allows for creating fully
functional new eyes
so you ice without mutability will see
all these four things throughout the
talk as we go through a key thing is we
primarily develop on net core for our
web applications now and every aspect of
the safe stack runs really nicely on net
core there's no hackery needed to make
it work that means it runs on Windows
Mac and Linux I'd historically been
using OS X for all my day-to-day
development of a show up stuff and for
the past couple years but I've now
switched over to Windows now we've got
people using Linux in the community as
well to do all their day-to-day and to
end web application development in terms
of tooling
there's f-sharp plugins for Visual
Studio 2017 Visual Studio code JetBrains
rider so if you want to write web
applications in a shell you're still
able to use a lot of the tooling that
you're used to there's even more
esoteric tooling as well if you use
things like vim or Emacs or sublime text
there's plugins for those available as
well so why did we come up with these
components for safe well within
composition IT we'd been writing web
applications and we started to notice a
trend in the sort of tools that we were
using across all of our projects and so
we wanted to share this experience of
how we're writing web applications with
F sharp a lot of people who are new to
our shop
say well you know I've done HelloWorld
I've done a few example Cohen's or
tutorials but I don't know how to apply
that to broader concepts in the outside
world so we wanted to share these
experiences with those people we also
noticed clear overlap with how others in
the eff shop world were writing web apps
there are other people all around Europe
in the US who were writing web apps in a
similar style we sat down we talked to
them and we noticed that they were using
the same tool chains the same sort of
libraries and finding the same sort of
results as we were and Saturn as your
fable and elvish actually made quite a
nice acronym in the end so we thought
well let's get logo as well well let's
now dive in to the components in a bit
more detail first up let's look at
back-end services with saturn so saturn
is a library which exists within the
asp.net ecosystem and we have this thing
called saturn at the top it's
essentially a set of configuration
helpers and abstractions over the top of
a lot of low-level functional concepts
which help with things like
configuration or plumbing over your
application together that sits on top of
this library called giraffe giraffe is a
way of writing asp.net web applications
using functional concepts so if you've
used asp.net core already you'll have
likely done things like create a
controller which inherits from this
class that's not
idiomatic F shop in F sharp everything
is based on functions and we want to
compose functions together as much as
possible and so that's what giraffe lets
us do as I mentioned giraffe sits on top
of asp.net which means you get the
entirety of the asp.net ecosystem along
with it so if there is some library that
you need to use which is only available
within asp.net you're still able to use
within safe so if you need to use
something like Active Directory
authentication which is a bit of a pain
to get right yourself there's already
the asp.net core middleware that exists
for that from Microsoft and the other
advantage of this is it means it still
runs on top of kestrel the high
performance asp.net web server so you're
still able to get all that great
performance that the asp.net team has
put together but you're able to write it
all in a shop as well
I mentioned that Saturn provides some
abstractions over the top of giraffe
concepts one of the things it provides
is this application computation
expression and we'll see in-depth
examples of these over the next few
slides this is where you do things like
your app level configuration and routing
so if you've done any asp.net core this
is the equivalent of your like I web
host builder and I application builder
then there's this thing called a Rooter
which is your way of routing HTTP
requests to actual code within your
application and these are all composable
so you can have reuters direct into
roofkies direct into reuters all the way
down the chain there's also this thing
called a pipeline which is a scope level
configuration so like the Rooter level
configuration and other contextual data
so this includes things like
authentication to say you know any
request that goes through this router
needs to be authenticated adding headers
manipulating headers status codes
serialization all these kind of things
go in your pipelines and then you've
also got this controller abstraction
that Saturn introduces which is designed
to be a high-level abstraction for a lot
of crud operations so your create read
update delete these are all handled by
Saturn with controllers let's take a
look at these in a bit more detail let's
look at configuration to start with so
the configuration of asp.net core apps
is entirely through a computation
expression which means you get this real
no strongly-typed configuration to have
a look at an example we've got this
application computation expression here
this is the same type of things that is
used to do asynchronous workflows in a
shop or task based workflows in a shop
in this case though is applied to
configuration so we get the opportunity
to say easily the URL that you're going
to listen to is this URL you're going to
direct it through this Rooter you're
going to use a memory cache everything
static is going to go through this
public path let's configure our
serialization for our services and then
we'll use gzip encoding as well to
compress everything down and then it's
just a case of a simple run app and it
works
Saturn then has this thing called Ritter
a Ritter
is how Saturn links a URL path to a
function that's going to execute anytime
that URL gets hit rooters are strongly
typed even in URL parameters which can
be quite a weird thing to see and we'll
see that in just a second and as I
mentioned before they're all composable
so you can have a Rooter the directs to
a Rooter the directs to a Rooter all the
way down the chain so here I've got to
example Reuters in a shop will read
bottom to top because our dependencies
need to be specified first within a shop
so let's look at this main router at the
bottom first and for that we've created
a Rooter and we say anything that comes
in on this API office endpoint we're
going to forward through to our office
router that we defined elsewhere
alternatively if we get a get request on
that /foo path then we'll call that get
foo function as I mentioned there
composable so we've got office Rooter
here that's defined above we can then
say I get slash within that router will
return all offices or if we do a get F
and then / % s we'll get it by its
distinct ID
now if you've got some history in like C
or those kind of languages where they do
the printf with percent based formatting
then you'll be aware that that percent s
means a string so what Saturn does is it
says that this function here this get
office by ID needs to take a string as
its first parameter if you were to have
office get office by ID take a decimal
or an integer or anything else you'll
get a compilation error and your
application won't compile until you
either fix get office by ID to take a
string or until you change your path
parameter into a percent D for an
integer for example sometimes you don't
want that low-level Rooter configuration
that sometimes you want a bit higher
level and that is access through this
controller abstraction so this is an
abstraction for dealing with object
based resources so if you think of a
Rooter as a means of accessing an
individual function a controller is a
way of grouping together functions which
operate on a single object so an object
might be a person or a room or a meeting
and so it provides abstractions for crud
operations and this is fully composable
with Reuters and other controllers as
well so here's an example of a couple of
controllers will read from the bottom
again upwards so I've got an office
controller here which is designed to
list all of the offices that you might
have in a businesses Network we have an
index here and this provides us with the
context and let says list all of the
offices we have a show which provides us
with the context again so that's the
HTTP context that provides everything
related to the web request like the user
who's logged in what head has came
through all those kind of details as
well as an ID
and we can perform specific operations
using that ID we can also use this sub
controller here which says if we come in
at a URL like slash office /id slash
meetings we want to redirect down to
this meetings controller as well so in
this case we're passing in the office ID
that we got from the parent and then
we're able to do an index of all the
meetings happening within that specific
office or an individual meeting
happening within that specific
office so as I say it's all designed
with composability in mind so you can
really group specific parts of your
application together nicely and link
everything together in a completely type
safe way its sub control at a certain
thing yes it is so this is part of this
controller computation expression what's
those sorry
so this why is this not specified in the
Rooter this is because this is a child
of the office controller so it's slash
office slash and office ID slash a
meeting slash a meeting ID so it's a
child you end up with this tree based
hierarchy of all your resources and so
if it was in your Rooter you'd lose out
on the office aspect there we also have
the opportunity to create pipelines
within Saturn so these are composable
components and which handle every stage
of the incoming requests so pipelines
operate on both the request and the
response and let us do three operations
we can either modify the request to do
things like add new headers modify the
response to serialize the output or just
drop the request entirely if we were had
like an authentication failure for
example and pipelines look like this
essentially where we've got a pipeline
here we're adding a request ID which is
the asp.net core request ID middleware
and we're setting a header on the
response and now any time any request
comes in it'll be passed through this
pipeline before being handled and sent
back to the client because Saturn is
built on top of giraffe which is on top
of that feed on that core it allows us
to use all the asp.net core middleware
also we can run Saturn wherever we can
host asp.net core which means that if
you want to you can run Saturn on
kestrel you can run it on as your
functions you can run it on Adria
slander you've got a lot of
opportunities for different hosting
mechanisms as well so F shops great in
the backend I personally really like
statically typed languages which means
that I'm not a particular fan of
JavaScript and I've never been very good
at it
so fable is a compiler which allows us
to write F shop and cross compile it
into JavaScript except it doesn't just
turn it into JavaScript it turns it into
nice readable modern JavaScript if
you've used any JavaScript cross
compilers in the past they can either
just operate isolated on the code or
they can make this real mess of an
ecosystem around them yes
is it fable because of Babel yes it is
so by using fable we're able to share
code so we can take our types and
functions which exist in there donate
core API and also compile them to
JavaScript using fable and then consume
them within our initial occations
because of the way that fable is
designed it is an integral part of the
JavaScript ecosystem as well it doesn't
reinvent all the JavaScript oink so it
integrates with web pack if you're using
web pack in your day-to-day development
if you want to debug your web
applications you can use react in the
Redux dev tools as well and it allows
you to use all the existing jobs for it
libraries that are out there so you just
have to create a wrapper over the top
and it's consumable within a shop and
you get full typing over the top of it
we now want to be able to do our actual
uisce n f-sharp as well f-sharp allows
us to do things like mutability but it's
not the recommended approach we want to
use as much idiomatic f-sharp as
possible and we can achieve that by
using this thing called elvish now in my
personal opinion the UI programming is
actually really difficult and it's
really easy to make it a lot harder
as far as I'm concerned any mutability
in the UI ends up being a bit of a
liability like as soon as you start
doing anything like complexity relating
to handling async operations and you're
trying to work out where this call by
its going to end up running am I going
to be running to callbacks at once to
get web requests responses then it just
gets to be complicated quickly you also
lose a lot of composability of
components I've found so doing things
like mvvm it's really easy to think yes
this is going to be easy to compose but
ultimately you end up building quite
specific components I found and there's
also this difficulty of if you're
running within a desktop application
manipulating the UI on just one thread
and checking am I on the right thread do
I need to change threads before I can do
anything and it just gets really
complicated and honestly I'm not that
smart I would rather do things as easily
as possible so what we want to do is we
want to bring some functional
programming concepts to the UI because
functional programming is all about
making data transformations as simple as
possible so how do we do that within our
UI well let's start with an initial UI
state the things that is the bare
minimum for your application to show
that works and what we'll do is we'll
render that state out to the UI will see
some more concrete examples of this
later when I show some of the safe
tooling
let's exists as well then anytime
somebody interacts with your UI what
we're going to do is we're going to
create an event and that event is then
going to be handled which creates a new
state and once we've got a new state we
render the new state and because we're
rendering an entirely new application we
don't need to worry about is this thing
going to get interrupted by your
callback from a web response that's
finished all these kind of things so to
visualize this
we can see we've got a model let's start
from the top we have our existing model
and we're going to render it into the V
and send it to the browser now whenever
there's a page request or a UI event
we're gonna update create an updated
model and then render it out again that
anytime we also receive an event we'll
bring in our existing model and we can
use that as the basis for what's going
to happen next so let's take a look at
an example of how this happens in elvish
here's a counter example which is super
simple we've got our counter which is
just an integer and we've got three
commands associated with it so we can
either increment and counter detrimental
counter or reset the counter that's our
model it consists of our state and our
events or commands we then have a view a
view takes in two things a model which
is the counter state that I mentioned
previously and this dispatch function
this dispatch function is how we can
push new events into the render loop so
I'm gonna use this F sharp view helper
library here which is using react under
the hood and I'm gonna render a div with
a h1 and a button and I've got this on
click Handler and anytime somebody
clicks the plus button we're gonna
dispatch an increment event also we're
gonna render out our current counter
value and we'll finally have another
button for a decrement now we have an
initial State this is the very first
thing that we're going to show in our UI
and in this case I've counter is zero
you could make that whatever you wanted
there is nothing stopping you saying
your counter starts at 100 or 200 or a
million it's entirely up to you
is what makes sense to your application
then within the update we take in two
things the command or event and the
current model so then all we do is we
match the command with the three options
that are available increment decrement
and reset and we generate a new state
based on that because this is a shop and
because our events are a discriminated
Union and this is a pattern match if at
any point we fail to consider for
example the reset event we'll get a
compiler warning or even a compiler
error which says you've not considered
all the options if you don't consider
this your application might break and
then we return a new state yes Canton
looks like a variable but it's not a
variable so what is it counter is a
value so it's like a variable that
f-sharp is immutable nothing changes
so it's just a fixed value yeah so it
looks like we're changing it what we're
actually doing is we're creating an
entirely new state like we're doing here
and then returning that new state out
because then what happens is we have
this program that make simple at the
bottom which glues our components
together and says whatever comes out of
update goes into view whatever comes out
of view goes into update and does the
cycle for you program duck run starts it
up and I should also mention that it
uses react under the hood so you get all
the react dev tools with it and you get
all the performance that comes with
react as well elvish isn't just for the
web either you can do console
applications in it WPF xamarin forms so
anything that xamarin forms can tell you
you can create fully mutable
applications using a shop and elvish
and as we've just seen fable we also
deploy all our safe apps to Azure we've
tried to make it as easy as possible to
do one click deploy and do it right so
it's not right click deploy within
visual studio it's a command line
command so you can integrate it within
your CI system local development process
etc we've created arm as your resource
manager templates so you can create
easily repeatable deployments for all
the components that you need within a
safe application and we include scripts
to allow you to deploy from CLI fake
scripts build server etc there's full
integration with as your platform
services because of F sharp we're able
to use typewriters one of the type
providers that's included as part of the
safe tooling is the Israel storage type
provider which provides you type safe
access to data that is stored within
Azure storage so if you've got a blob in
Azure storage you're able to access that
in a strongly typed manner similarly you
can get the same sort of strong typing
on top of as your tables with in Azure
storage it's also hooked up to a pin
sites so as soon as you're running your
back-end server you can start pushing
events out to application insights on
Azure and that also leads to integration
from fable as I said we wanted to make
it as easy as possible for people to
start working with web apps in a shop
yes there's question is there a type of
rider for cosmos DB I'm not so I'm not
sure can't answer that right now so the
safe experience as it stands I've
mentioned four components which we use
for developing web applications so key
question is what does safe actually add
well the key thing is it's a terminology
for sharing experiences as it stands a
lot of the f-sharp ecosystem it exists
in a lot of independent silos you had
people doing fable stuff you had people
doing L miss stuff as your stuff and
back-end web stuff we wanted to bring
those all together so at conferences in
blog posts etc people can say we're
using safe and everybody knows what
components are then involved that means
that it makes it really easy for us to
create automated touring for creating a
safe app as well it also means we can
get better end-to-end documentation from
dotnet neo2 how do I add some complex
feature that spans across the whole
stack and it also gives us better
end-to-end toy and I'm going to
demonstrate it to link shortly it also
means that we can do really in-depth
training and samples so not just how do
I build a web application using this F
shot component but how do I build a
complete well architected F sharp
solution to a web application problem
the first thing we did with that is we
realized the problem with the current
death process the lot of people
undertake currently it looks something
like the following you'll start with
this change code at the top your write
out a load of code you click f5 click
debug run whatever and it compile in
build you'd wait awhile whilst that
happened you might go off and get a
drink comes back your application starts
up your debug is attached and you'd hit
a breakpoint and start trying to work
out what's changed you'd then change
your code recompile restart read Evoque
etc it's a process that adds a lot of
overhead time and makes it really easy
to get distracted as part of the
development flow and so to change that
we've embraced tools like dotnet watch
and web pack that allow for automated
reloading of your application as you
make changes as you go on so you make us
all change to one line you only need to
change that one line within your
application so it's really quick and you
can see the changes happening in real
time and I'll show that shortly
another thing is because we now have
this stack of tools we can add
commercial support a lot of the tooling
that exists in the F sharp world doesn't
have the same backing as stuff like
asp.net does if you've got a problem
with asp.net you can phone up Microsoft
and say it's not working and they'll
help you with your problem within the F
sharp world a lot of the libraries we're
open source so this meant that it was
difficult for commercial adoption
because it was quite a big risk for a
lot of companies there's a few
consultancies around the world now who
have decided to adopt safe and say
they'll provide full support for any
problems you might have or might
encounter during development of web
applications using safe which takes a
lot of the risk off a lot of new
companies looking to adopt it yes so
safe is still completely open-source and
I'll show github repos and everything
towards the end another benefit is we
get consistent documentation which means
that we can do end-to-end coverage of
functionality across the whole stack so
a lot of components within the web world
don't exist in isolation if you want to
do authentication sure your back-end
changes are important but it's also
important to know what changes on the
front end to make it work by having safe
we can say to do end-to-end
authentication you need to do X Y and
Zed if you want to do and to end
continuous integration you need to do a
B and C so this allows developers to get
up speed on full stack features really
quickly and so if you're interested in
seeing what that documentation currently
looks like it's on safe stack github do
slash Docs
the next thing that we came up with was
a new safe template to make it easy to
go from nothing to something that you
can then iterate on and change easily
so to do that we've got a dotnet core
template which provides a variety of
options you can choose what you want to
use for your back-end web server so you
can choose to use just sat or you can
choose to use saturn or just giraffe
that sits underneath it if you don't
feel like you need that configuration
level there's layout options so you can
have either I don't want any CSS I just
want the bear application there's this
library called Fulmer which some of you
might have used Bulmer which is a
library like bootstrap
so it's CSS components to make it easier
to develop UI based within the browser
Fulmer is a type safe way of accessing
that so it provides abstractions for I
want to create a table in Bulmer or a
section or container or you can choose
to use Fullmer with one of the Balmer
templates that's available as well if
you don't want to use HTTP as your
communication mechanism for whatever
reason there's also a library called
fable remoting which is essentially kind
of similar to RPC but built on top of
HTTP with a lot of easy escape hatches
so if you want to get something up and
running quickly a lot of people in the
HR community community like using the
fable remoting library there's also a
variety of different deployment options
so you can either choose I don't want to
deploy this I want to include my own
process later in the future
there's also docker so you can just say
I want to deploy this into a docker
container and it will create all of your
doctor feels that you need it'll also
add steps to your build process that
says
here's where all the files need to be
within my doc container or there's also
the option to deploy to us you are this
is a really full featured as your
deployment so you get resource manager
templates
there's also full integration with as
your ad within the build scripts so you
can deploy locally from your machine
without having to do things like
configure applications within as your
active directory so there's really no
barriers to just doing a deployment
locally or even if you want to in your
continuous integration server I should
point out that this is actually already
out of date because last week there was
also Google cloud platform support moved
in so if you want to deploy on to Cuba
Nettie's on GCP then that's all included
as part of the template as well and you
can do deploy Google and it provides you
with all the changes to your build
script and all the extra tooling that
you need to deploy to GCP and there's
also this ability to specify how you
want to handle your JavaScript
dependencies so do you want to use just
for all NPM or would you prefer to use
jaan for whatever reason for that we
recommend using docker and just taking
the docker container and put it on to
elastic container service that's tended
to be the solution that a lot of people
find easiest
what do I mean by Donaire template yes I
mean a dotnet
command-line template so you can just do
dotnet new safe and what you end up with
is this fully featured application I'll
show that in just a minute as well
throughout the dotnet new lifecycle it
creates all the required templates that
you need so you'll get a fake script to
handle your local development and also
your CI server that can do things like
build and run setting up all of your hot
reloading and it also includes things
like deployment as well so you can do
fake build deploy and it will take your
local code and deploy it up to Azure it
also includes things like docker files
as well which will bundle together all
of your F shop and fable together
package it up nicely put it all in the
right folder hierarchy create all the
environment variables that you need so
you can then just do docker run your
container and it all works straight out
of the box so let's take a look at the
dotnet new tooling and a template that's
available so if I've come to my command
line here
it's unfortunate a little bit small but
essentially all I've had to do is dotnet
new safe and that's creates all the
files I need and now I've just done fake
build target run so this is my code base
and if I just open up my web browser
then this is your default safe
application that you get created so this
is all coming from a back-end web server
that's running on asp.net core using the
satin abstractions I've got a front-end
application where I can click the
buttons and the UI changes one thing
that you might have noticed the
eagle-eyed among two you might have seen
that in the top right corner Redux dev
tools is now
this application because it's built
using elvish is able to use the Redux
dev tools so I click in there you can
see all the changes they've been made
within my application so you can go
through the history and say we've got
this is how the UI has changed and the
value in the counter has changed so at
any point I can say let's let's jump
back to there and my UI goes back in
time to what happened after that event
which makes debugging really easy
because you can just change history and
jump forward again change history
jump forward again and keep repeating
like that until you solve the problem
yes so question was in this example
we've got the state as a record type yes
you absolutely can use Union types as
your state I'm working on one
application at the minute where that's
exactly what I need because I've got
this complex state machine in my front
end and so on then doing is a pattern
match on my experiences Union for state
and discriminated union for messaging so
within our application that's now
running this is running from my command
line here using fake which is f shop
make the F shop built all that a lot of
the community users one of the cool
things that it includes is this thing
called hot module reloading and I am
really hoping that the demo gods are
kind to me today because when this works
it's really cool so just to go back when
the initial state loaded that counter
was at 42 it's now at 45 I don't like
this messaging though I don't want it to
say press buttons to manipulate counter
so what I'm going to do is say push
buttons to manipulate counter I'm going
to cross my fingers
I'm gonna save it my command line is
going to see that I've changed it it's
going to recompile and if you look there
the text that was there has changed but
what hasn't changed is my current state
so my current state within my
application was 47 because I press the
button a few times I've changed my
application though and it's
automatically reloaded before I'd even
change back to my browser so I can then
choose whatever I want to say here or
even just change this again anywhere
reload and the application reloads
without having to without me having to
start from scratch to get back to where
I was debugging so it makes it as easy
as possible to get started with a shop
for web development let's pick out a few
key things that are included we've added
editor extension support so if you're
brand new to F shop and you've never
done anything before we include
extension recommendations so if you pick
this up in vs code you just need to
click this install all and it will
include the F sharp plugin for visual
studio code it'll include the chrome
remote debugger and a couple of other
features as well to allow support for
things like editor config as well
we includes three projects so we have a
client a server and then we've got some
shared code between them if we look at
our shared code we can share our types
across our client and server and so this
is where you'd expand to include things
like your contract or any functionality
that was common across both components
there's a client application so this is
a full Elvish application
you can see the things that we talked
about when we went through elvish where
we can see our model our messages our
initial values which come from a remote
server somewhere we can also see all of
our update logic and our view down here
as well with everything hooked up
together on the server side we've got a
simple back-end server setup with an API
so you can retrieve your applique or
retrieve your values from your back-end
server I mentioned the build script this
deployment is done as a non deployment
so there's no as your or anything like
that
this is just the raw build script which
will actually do clean build and run
which will start the hot module
reloading which works on both the front
end and the back end so I can change
something within my server api that
reloads and my front end will reflect
that as well and because web pack is
quite a complicated thing we've also
included a full web pack template so you
don't need to worry about setting up
how does fable interact with NPM or
anything like that or anything else
within the JavaScript ecosystem so this
includes all of your bundling for fable
it includes
all of the hot module reloading as well
yeah can you use components written in
react Jess I'm going to come on to that
in a little bit so I'll cover that in
the next section right so that is the
safe template as you can see it's
designed to make it as easy as possible
to go from nothing to having an F shot
web application that you can hack on but
it's not enough to just have that
initial how do I do or how do I get
started it's also important to have that
continuous learning of what's the next
step along the way and so for that
there's a few example applications that
have been put together by the broader
community for the SAF stack so the first
one is the safe dojo this is something
that we put together which is a set of
tool or it's a safe app that's got a lot
of gaps within it with a guided
instructions document so you go through
and it tells you which bits you need to
change and shows the sorts of things
that you should be looking at as key
parts of the safe stack there's also the
safe bookstore so this is a much larger
application this includes things like
storage deployment with dock your it
includes for authentication with JW TS
this is sort of reference architecture
for how do I start to fit everything
together with safe and a new one that
we've put together in the past few
months is safe search which is another
larger application and we're going to
come onto this in just a second but this
includes significant integration with a
lot of as your services as the name may
imply one of those is as your search so
these are just designed to show the next
step of what should my architecture look
like how should I be developing my
applications in F sharp with safe so
let's take a look at the safe search as
I mentioned
I'm just going to call out a few little
bits and pieces within this so this is
all available on github it's not a small
project it's quite big so it's a bit of
stuff to get your teeth into if you're
interested in learning more about safe
but this is an application which lists
UK property prices and uses the as your
search services it uses your storage and
it also uses things like Google Maps and
react component so you're able to use
existing react components that haven't
been written in their shop and this is a
example reference of how you can do that
so I just wanted to call out a few
little bits that relate to the things
that were in the safe stack which you
can see within this application here so
we've got our view here this is an
afront and as I say it's not a small
application you can see by the scroll
bar there that there's a few hundred
lines of code in this it's not just a
dummy application there is significant
functionality here and so you're able to
see how we do things like work with
react to use existing components that
might have been created outside of the F
sharp ecosystem entirely up to how your
application works you can have so
question is is this just one view for
the whole app or can you split it up you
can split it up so you can have multiple
pages and there is an Elvish library to
do navigation based changes so if you
wanted to do a full single page
application you can say if it's on hash
page one show this view if it's on hash
page to show this for you this one
though it's one at one view
there's also a back-end and so you can
see how we use the composability
of saturn to combine together multiple
independent features of the application
we've got an API for search and API for
transactions and API for postcode lookup
as well and we're able to compose those
all together from different parts of the
application one of the cool things I
thought I'd mention is there's your
storage type provider that you can use
so if we take a look here we've just got
a simple schema written up for what our
table looks like and we've got a
postcodes table which is got a postcode
with a latitude and longitude within the
type of rider you specify this JSON file
your compiler then goes through and
looks at this tables JSON file and
builds up the types automatically for
you there's no code generation or
anything like that what happens is it
provides the metadata to the compiler
that says this thing this postcode is a
string latitude is a float longitude is
a float and then what you're able to do
is you get this as your dot tables here
so there's your type there tables static
type on there and all the tables that
are accessible within your as your
subscription are available as types on
that as your tables type the next thing
is the safe dojo that I mentioned so
this is an introductory dojo if you've
got experience with their shop you can
finish this within about an hour if
you've got no prior F sharp experience
takes about an hour and a half and this
has a full set of steps on here's what
you need to do to get up and running
with the safe stack of tooling
so that's all available on github if
you're interested in learning more about
safe
I'd recommend following at safe stack on
Twitter that's where a lot of the new
news gets posted there's also the full
github organization for safe that's got
examples of applications like the
bookstore
it's got examples of using things like
react native if you want to use react
native we're safe there's also all the
safe templates in there so if you want
to go out and add digital ocean
deployment to the safe template and
contribute that that would be more than
welcomed safe stack github do is a
webpage where it links to all the
documentation and everything like that
I'll give you my information again if
you've got any questions about this that
you think of tomorrow or in a week's
time please feel free to email me
Anthony at composition IT comm or
contact me on twitter at brynbrown 93
and with that we've got five minutes
left so I'm happy to take some more
questions on things that I might not
have covered yes
one question there how complete is fable
I know a lot of people are running fable
applications in production now whether
it's front-end applications but I've
also spoken to some people who are now
running fable on nodejs to run their
entire back-end so they've not been
encountering too many problems there
might be the odd thing that comes up I
think the latest one was like there was
a minor inconsistency was how GUI dot
knew worked which has since been updated
and fixed but it's we're at Fable 2.1
now so it's been fairly well tested and
it's fairly
strong in the production-ready sense any
more questions yet one question though
yeah what would be a reason to use fable
remoting if you wanted to just get a
proof of concept up and running really
simple in your shed you just say I've
got this type and your back ends you can
then say expose this type and your front
ends you can just say consume this type
so it's it's not in the same league as
like WCF and those kind of tools it's
designed to be really lightweight and
easy to just easily change it if you
want not soap and wisdom and everything
else that it you have to bring in yeah
question there do we have do we have an
integration or an example of integration
with OAuth I'm not a hundred percent
sure let me get back to you on that
next question yeah yep yep yeah
how would I convince people to switch I
would probably show the amount of less
time it takes to write the solutions in
a shop than it takes to write in C shop
we found that it takes about a month two
months to get most where that's done in
a shop in the sense of well scoped
well-defined projects a lot of our
customers come to us because we'll give
them a quote to say we'll do this in two
months
whereas a lot of others say six months
so that's our key benefit another key
benefit is the amount of stories which
exist where people have said I've
deployed this application into
production and there were no books when
it went live you know it was a case of I
clicked deploy we handed it over to
users and there was no why is it all
stopped you know why is this bug on ie
obscure version because you're using
things like fable which are backed by
tools like Babel you get really
consistent results across all browsers
because you're using tools like F sharp
you're getting really consistent code
across all browsers as well so you get
things like the type safety guarantees
with URLs you get things like the
guarantees that you're not going to
encounter a case that you can't that you
haven't considered with things like
elvish it abstracts away a lot of those
simple mistakes that are easy to make
when you're in that last kind of throw
or in those last kind of throws of this
needs to be deployed today it's really
easy to make a mistake because you've
changed one thing somewhere and not
considered how it affects one thing on
the other side of your application with
a shot because of its type safety we
don't encounter those kind of bugs as
much yes another question here
yep do we ever drop down to the
JavaScript when we're debugging the
front end code the majority of the time
when I'm debugging front-end code I'm
probably going to be using something
like Chrome or the Firefox debugger and
because Fable generates source maps I'm
debugging a shop within the browser so
as an example if I come into here and go
f12 and debugger and if I come down to
web pack and go into source client then
I'll add my breakpoint onto the F shop
directly rather than having to deal with
JavaScript you can do the same in Visual
Studio code yes next question the one
here how do you get the type safety
within JavaScript if you're using a
react component what you have to do is
write out experiences Union with all
your possible props that you can use if
you've got a typescript definition of it
though there is a tool called ts2 fable
where you provide a typescript
definition file and it generates a fable
wrapper for you so let's use the easiest
way if you do want to use something
really obscure that might be from the
ie6 days that your company is having to
embed as a component and nobody knows
how it works then you'll have to do a
manual wrapper over the top of that but
Fable provides a lot of helpers that
make it as easy to work across that sort
of weird dynamic to very static barrier
that exists any more questions one
question there yep
is suave in safe as well we essentially
said that suave is nice but you don't
get that whole ecosystem that you get
with Saturn if you want to use suave go
for it it's supported in the template
but ultimately our recommendation tends
to be because you get kestrel because
you get the ad where slander support
because you get all the asp.net core
middleware that already exists saturn
makes it a lot easier and giraffe
provides essentially the same api across
suave as you'd get within a speed on the
access was there some licensing drama i
can't remember off the top of my head
any more questions we are slightly over
at the minute so is there any helpers
full testing especially integration
testing within a shop there's tools like
canopy which tend to be the primary way
of testing like your full integration
within your browser as well oh yeah yeah
okay yeah we tend to just write those
kind of things in expecto so just create
function that tests your functionality
across both whether it's just a Web API
call or just use the asp.net core test
server if you need to any more questions
I think there's one that yeah blazer so
what do I think a blazer I think it's a
long way off being like everybody's
going to be using it as it sends with it
being webassembly I think you still need
to bring in an entire dotnet runtime to
use within the browser if I'm not
mistaken which I'm sure one day there'll
be a solution to that but it means you
get quite a big bundle size as it stands
like
yeah yeah exactly so it's I'm really
excited for what its gonna do because
hopefully it's going to make it easy to
make big nice Interop across other
languages into the browser but I think
there's a way to go just yet so I'm not
sure I'm keep an eye on it because
people have done F sharp towing so the
web shocker people have done a bolero
library which allows you to use web
assembly within web shopper with that I
think should we call it a day if anybody
has got any other questions then please
feel free to grab me and ask or as I say
Twitter email I'm happy to answer any
[Applause]